gideon gora has lived in lima district
all his life age 74 he says over the
years the rains have become more and
more erratic drought induced by the El
Nino weather pattern has cut some always
maize harvest by half and reduced water
levels in dams and rivers we don't eat
in the morning and in the afternoon we
eat only at night we eat as little as
possible so that the food can last
longer president amos minagawa has
declared this latest drought a national
disaster and the United Nations wants
more help to prevent a humanitarian
crisis it's raised its appeal to
international donors to 331 million
dollars truly are marching toward
starvation if we're not there to help
them 2.3 million people in this country
by this fall it will be substantially
higher at 3.6 million people because a
lean season season is coming upon us
then by early next year we're looking at
five point five five point three give or
take those numbers mean about a third of
the country's 15 million population will
need food aid some of the money raised
would be used to buy food provided clean
water and give cash handouts to
vulnerable families but raising all the
money needed could be difficult Zimbabwe
is competing with other crises around
the world such as Syria Yemen and South
Sudan making an already dire situation
even worse tropical cyclone edye
devastated parts of an aquiline province
in the east of the country earlier this
year
heavy rains flash floods and strong
winds destroyed crops leaving thousands
homeless and hungry the cash-strapped
government said aspiring grain from
other countries to replenish stocks we
as government are doing our part we are
doing allows not merely sitting back and
working for our colleagues from abroad
UN and others to assistance were doing
something ourselves and we therefore
ministry looking after social protection
problems but many Zimbabweans already
frustrated by rising inflation and a
weak economy feel their government isn't
doing enough gideon gora is one of them
he only has a few bags of maize left
before he completely runs out
he says he's praying for rain or
humanitarian aid to reach him whichever
comes first
Jairo Matassa al Jazeera Lima Zimbabwe